Angular's got a ton of moving parts, but
we finally made it to the last
one we'll be looking at, routing.
Up until this point we've worked
with apps that have just one view.
And that's fine, but
it's not very functional or interactive.
Single page applications typically
have many different views or
screens that you can interact with.
A router handles loading
these views based on the URL.
When we generate an angular
app with Yo Angular,
it asks us if we want to
include a number of modules.
One of the options is angular-route.
This routing module works well, but
it's kind of limited since it
doesn't allow for nested views.
We want to have specific
sections of the page update and
change while the rest stays the same.
So instead of using this
angular-route module,
we'll use the community built
routing module called UI Router.
The documentation for the UI Router
module is incredibly detailed.
Make sure to also check out the website
in the sample app to see all
of the functionality UI Router offers.
Since UI Router doesn't come as
part of the default installation,
we need to add it to our project.
The Angular generator uses
Bower to install Angular.
So let's use Bower to install ui-router.
Don't forget to add the -s to save
ui-router to the Bower config file.
One of the files that's created when
we generate an app with the yoangular
command is a Grunt file.
This file manages a lot of
the development process,
from watching files for
changes to reloading the browser.
One of the cool things is that
it can pair with other commands,
like the bower command we just used.
When we installed ui-router with bower,
grunt saw that and
included it in our index file.
Everything that we've been building up
to this point has all been inside our
udaciMeals module.
We created the module and then attached
controllers and services to it.
Ui-router is a module itself and
contains its own inner components.
Back when we created our module we
passed an empty array of dependencies.
Now we have to add ui-router
to that list so we can use it.
Just like injecting
a service into a controller,
to inject one module into another
we just add the name as a string.
So this is injecting the ui-router
module into our udaciMealsApp module.
A word of caution though,
all over the docs it's ui-router, but
when you include it it's ui.router.
This little guy's tripped
me up several times.
So watch out that he
doesn't get you too.
We've looked at why ui-router is
better than the default router module.
We've added ui-router to our project,
and
we've injected it into
the udaciMeals module.
Let's take a look at how to
set up ui-router to manage
the state of our app.